holy cow it has been a crazy day here at
Rubin report headquarters we got a major
major announcement that is sort of been
leaking through the internet as the day
has gone by but we got a major
announcement coming it's just been crazy
or we have had everybody on my team has
been here doing a thousand different
things as you guys know I'm heading off
the grid in a couple days for the month
of August we'll get back to that in just
a little bit but there is a reason we're
doing this live stream out of nowhere
this little impromptu live stream we
only gave you a warning about two
minutes ago and the reason for that is
that I am I am beyond thrilled
elated crazed with joy overjoyed insert
endless adjectives of happiness to
finally today be able to share with you
guys I think I got this going with no
glare how am i doing guys my book
don't burn this book free thinking in an
age of unreason is officially available
for pre-sale today you can go to don't
burn this book dot-com and the reason
that I am doing this live stream right
now is that every single copy no matter
how many thousands of copies we sell
today I am going to personally sign a
book plate for every single one so you
will get my signed signature on a
sticker the official don't burn this
book sticker which you can put in the
book or if you get the e-book you can
put it on the back of that or you can
put it on your laptop you can put it
above your bed you can put it on the
side of your car whatever works so every
single book no matter how many we sign
the first thousand that we sell today
are numbered so one one thousand two one
thousand nine hundred ninety seven one
thousand we've already sold a ton of
them I don't know how many but we've
been getting just blasted all day long
where we're jumping up on these Amazon
you know little categories that I'm
right behind Arnold Schwarzenegger I'm
like number three and political
autobiography is already and like a
whole bunch of other
fun stuff so anyway for the purposes of
this hour and a half or two hours that
we're gonna do here I want to tell you
guys a little bit about the book what
the writing process was like and all
that stuff so more than anything else
here's what you do go to don't burn this
book dot-com buy the book however you
want to buy it you can buy it on Amazon
you can buy it on Barnes & Noble's
Barnes & Noble excuse me
there's plenty of other places that you
can buy it then when you get your
receipt what you're gonna do is you're
gonna forward it to don't burn this book
at prh penguin Random House com don't
burn this book you can either do at prh
com or a penguin Random House dot-com
forward your receipt there it'll
obviously have your name on it include
your address and we are gonna send you
one of these book plates you will be the
first to have the book and you will know
that you got it on day one and and I'm
thrilled I'm just thrilled that we
finally there's been a lot of work you
know this last year has just been
completely into that last year they it
seems like the last ten years but the
last year and a half two years have just
been just been absolutely crazy between
touring with Jordan Peterson where we
did a hundred twenty some odd stops in
20-something countries and bounced all
over the world and that I that I was
able to just be part of the magic around
around Jordan and oh well speaking of
Jordan don't burn this book am i doing
here with glare foreword by Jordan
Peterson so I want to tell you a little
bit of insider stuff and I'll I'll tell
you a little bit about the book itself
but Jordan when we were in Oslo we were
doing a second show in Oslo and and most
of the shows sold out in ours some of
them sold out in minutes
I think the Stockholm shows sold out so
quickly that they added another show
because it sold out in like three
minutes or something we were in Oslo and
I got the call from my from my agent at
CAA we had we had been trying to figure
out a book deal and a bunch of people
had reached out to us and then if you
made some of you guys may remember about
a year ago there was this Playboy
profile on me which was really good and
then from there basically every
publishing house was reaching out and
they wanted to figure it out
and we went back and forth and then my
guys at CAA basically put the book up
for auction which is where all the
publishing houses come in they just make
their best offer anyway my agent calls
me he said we closed the deal this is
what we're doing I was beyond overjoyed
I ran into Jordans dressing room so I'm
in a little little dressing room on the
side Jordan's got the nice big dressing
room and he was in there with his wife
Tammy and oh and David my husband was
with me at the time so we walked in
there and we were we were just
absolutely thrilled and I told Jordan
this is about ten minutes before the
show so he's about to speak to you know
4,000 some odd people the shows in Oslo
were huge and I told him and he slapped
his hands together and he had this huge
huge smile on his face and he kind of
spun around in his chair and he was
absolutely just just thrilled for me and
without before I could even say anything
he said he said would you like me to
write the foreword for you and I was
like like how do you even respond to
that like now that I'm good Peterson no
foreword that'll be fine
so yes the foreword will be written by
Jordan Peterson we've gotten a whole
bunch of advance praise I don't want to
read all this stuff to you because it's
on if you go to don't burn this book
calm you can read some of the advance
praise but we've got advance praise from
ben shapiro and tucker carlson and peter
thiel and my friend Larry King and it's
it's been it's been quite an adventure
to get here so the book itself but I
want to tell you guys a little bit
related to the book is that it's really
been an adventure so I'm guessing that
most of you haven't written a book and
this is my first one and as some of you
know for the last couple years I've been
trying to write a book and I would start
and stop and I could never sort of I
could tell some stories but it was I was
having trouble sort of getting it to a
point where it was saying something that
was that was truly authentic meaningful
that would be worthy of you spending
your money on and then in the last year
between touring with Jordan and doing
the show and some of the the mob stuff
going after me in front page of the New
York Times and that ridiculous all right
article and and so many things and just
watching all of the things
that I've been talking about on this
show for years they were sort of Fringe
ideas three years ago right when I was
talking about like what was happening
with the left and the false cries of
racism and bigotry and all of those
things as ways of winning arguments
instead of actually winning arguments
with facts when I was talking about that
years ago it was just starting to bubble
up and I think that that's probably what
put me on a lot of your radars so if you
guys are liberals or let's say you were
lefties or maybe you're sort of
begrudging ly lefties now it's like I
was starting to say something that now
everyone sees is very obvious like
what's happening with the progressives
right now they've really gone off the
rails and they're just dragging the
Democrats with them where where are the
good Democrats where are the classical
liberals where are the old-school Blue
Dog Democrats we're in the JFK's I don't
know I talked about that in this book
and I come up with some prescriptions at
the end and if you're a conservative I
think what brought you here probably was
that you never saw someone that was kind
of decent and had some liberal beliefs
that treated you like a human and didn't
think you were a racist bigoted
homophobe and just by sharing my
feelings about this and then and then
talking to people not every week but
often about that sort of set of issues
this is all to the backdrop of the rise
of Trump and everything else and then
how this culture war has just burst
forth into everything right now it's
it's in our political system it's in our
it's on our education system all of
these things around censorship like
everything that we've talked about here
just kept sort of happening you know we
Brett Weinstein it at Evergreen State
being booted off campus basically for
fighting racism Lindsey Shepard at
wilfred laurier basically being you know
reprimanded because she showed a Jordan
Peterson video in class a guy like James
d'amour who fought the diversity memo at
Google like all of these people kept
walking through this room and then there
was sort of the rise of the of the
intellectual dark web and the whole crew
whether it's whether it's Peterson and
say Ben Shapiro and me probably leaning
a little
or right at this point or at least let's
say a little more Liberty minded and
then there's the guys that I think still
consider themselves left needs say the
Weinstein brothers and Sam Harris then a
whole crew of people that's something
that we did in this room which is in my
garage I mean I'm in my garage right now
started becoming really really
culturally relevant and then and then
you know the the endless haters and all
of that nonsense and the and the hit
pieces from from Vox and from HuffPo and
the rest of it and you know trying to
get Peabody jej I was trying to get
mayor Pete on the show some of you
remember this about a month and a half
ago and tweeted at his comms guy and the
guy said DME and then suddenly HuffPo
journalists and Vox journalists and a
guy from Media Matters all jumped in you
know called me all sorts of bad names
and we had already gone back and forth
with Buddha judges team via email about
getting him on the show and then they
backed out of that and it's just like
this this war that's happening about who
you can talk to and when you can talk to
them so that that is what this book is
about learning learning to to fight the
mob free thinking in an age of unreason
that's the subtitle because we right now
live in a time of unreason everyone is
sort of hysterical all the time and all
of those things okay so let me do a
quick reset here and then what we're
gonna do is as you guys by the book I am
going to start reading off names so
you'll hopefully get a shout out here I
don't know that I can read everybody's
name but they're just my guys are just
gonna give me live on the fly first
names only so first names only don't
worry about that we're not we're not
outing any of you as crazy right-wingers
don't worry about that but quick reset
don't burn this book calm every single
copy that we sell today I will sign
personally I have a brand new sharpie
right here so you're gonna get a signed
book plate which we've got right here
the official book plate I'm gonna sign
that and you'll be able to stick it
right into inside your book or on the
back of your book or this wherever you
want to put it on your car wherever
works so what you do is if you buy the
book you get the email receipt and then
forward that to don't burn this book at
pee
our H penguin Random House dot-com and
they'll take care of the rest the book
by the way comes out on April 28 2020
which I know seems like a long long time
from now
then there's there were several reasons
around that and some dates changed in a
few things there's a lot going on just
sort of culturally we were trying to
figure out timing you know obviously as
we roll into 2020 everything is going to
be completely bananas related to the
election and you know the election
obviously is November 2020 we wanted to
get a little bit ahead of that because
basically from like from like June to
November it's just gonna be endless
Trump book and it's just gonna be awful
garbage and and really that's not what
this is about
obviously I referenced Trump and I
talked about trumpism and I talked about
all of the things that I talked about in
this room but I didn't want to write a
book really about the election or just
with just another one of these generic
books so this really is this is my
journey and sort of what I've learned
the lessons that I've learned about
standing up to the mob and the rest of
it along the way so don't burn this book
calm and you can buy the book at Amazon
Apple Barnes & Noble Indy Bound etc etc
and then forward your receipt to don't
burn this book at prh com
let me just do a couple shoutouts real
quick Lillian I think you are officially
the first person to buy the book because
before we had even promoted anything on
Twitter you started doing a little
googling and you I believe are the first
person so as far as I'm concerned you're
getting one out of a thousand so the
first thousand that I signed today are
gonna be number these are just coming in
and all crazy order right now I see if I
see Helens in the document right now
adding people so yeah Lilly and you're
getting one out of a thousand the first
thousand I'm doing numbered signings of
and then from there then it's just I'm
just gonna sign all of them but we can't
number every single one no matter how
many thousand we sell today
okay so just quick shout outs to Joe
Paisano Christopher Warren Warren dead
my man who's been with me from the
beginning who hooked us up with the
sound panels in our studio thanks
brother Mike Robert Michael Kerry Laura
James Jacob David Larry Gary Kristen
Kristen mica Jeff Kyle Shana
and Raymond I'll stop right there for a
little bit and so let me just tell you a
little bit I don't I don't want to give
it all the way and we're still editing
right now so I the manuscript I sent it
in a couple of weeks ago and we are
still editing it right now and as you
guys know I'm also going off the grid in
two days on Thursday I am I am
completely shutting it down no computer
no phone no email no news no nothing
I am disappearing I have actually some
family here right now and I am
disappearing I am detoxing from all of
this this is sort of the the perfect
culmination of what this last year has
been I've done this August off-the-grid
thing for the last couple years and I
hope some of you will join me in doing
it in whatever way you can whether it's
just weekends or just not doing social
media a little bit or whatever but we
are not taking the month off so we
doubled up shows this month in July so
we've got four great shows coming for
you in August so there will be new shows
in August so my team will still be
tweeting out for me and instagramming
and all that stuff but I will have no
access to anything I have written out a
very short list of things that I
consider of like dire dire emergencies
that people close to me will be able to
reach me somehow but I won't even have
my phone on me they'll have to go
through David but that's it otherwise I
am completely gone till September 3rd
then on September 3rd we've got a guest
host who will sit in this very chair
look at me right there and and basically
fill me in on everything that I missed
Ben Shapiro did it last year I think
we're gonna do somebody else this year
we want to mix it up a little bit and
Ben is Ben is touring I think with the
with the AL guys so so that'll be fun so
I am gonna sign some of these while I'm
talking to you guys so I'm gonna just
grab a couple of these and I'm signing
to you here I'll just read off a couple
names real the real quick
Matthew Stacy sean.conner Patrick Calvin
Jacob Jennifer Kyle Artem Steve Murr
Jacob Missy Aaron Matthew Andrew Dave
Chris Sully
Alex Chris Lisa Jeffery and Pat okay so
I'm gonna sign a couple of these and
then I want to tell you a little bit
that's going to Lilian right there that
is number one oh wait here's number one
out of a thousand I want to make sure
that one gets to Lilian all right so
that's for Lily and the rest of these
are going
they can't be personalized obviously but
Lilian were taking good care and thank
you for that
so what I tried to do with the book is I
wanted to blend sort of some of the
stories and and things that have
happened in this room that I think have
been so culturally relevant with things
that you guys don't know about me so I
talk about personal stories and and
family stuff and things that I haven't
opened up that much about some in some
cases that I haven't opened up about at
all before and I sort of blend that to
sort of how I sort of came to be here
right now and how that relates to
everything else politically so I thought
maybe four I'll tell you a couple things
today but I thought maybe the best way
to do it for today is kind of just go
back to the to the beginning just sort
of career-wise because it has been quite
an adventure and you know it's funny
when you when you lock yourself in a
room for a couple days a week a couple
hours a day really trying to do
something that that's valuable and it it
can really make you just sort of rethink
rethink everything and I think rethink I
don't not just rethink everything I
think it can really help you solidify a
lot of the things that you think so I
think one of the things that I've really
learned in the last six months or so as
I've been writing this and especially in
the last couple months as it really was
was getting whittled down into something
especially towards towards the end when
I really wanted to say something say
something new and different is that it
makes you challenge all the things that
you think and when I had to do certain
research on certain fact-based things
and you know see potentially what my
blind spots are and things like that but
then also go into my family history and
be very very appreciative of of where I
came from and really we went way back
into my family history because we were
trying to find out what my American
story is and actually as I'm telling you
this right now
today is July 30th 2019
my dad is not watching this right now I
don't think because he is at his
retirement party my dad turned 72 months
ago and he's retiring after you know the
45 year career he's worked at the same
sales company in in midtown Manhattan
for the last 34 years I think it's 34
years he just celebrated this year and
he's retiring next week so it seems sort
of fitting to me as I'm writing this
sort of family story and all of this
that my dad maybe he's watching this
maybe you guys are watching right now
dad how are you if you're watching he at
the at the retirement party but it seems
sort of fitting like my dad's retiring
right now and I'm writing this story
about about that's about my family but
I'm not writing it to be an
autobiography and the book is not an
autobiography although there are
personal stories
it's more to frame like what my story is
that brings me here that is so exactly
the same as most of your stories are so
we were trying to break it down and it's
like on my on my dad's side my
great-great grandparents were were
first-generation immigrants from Belarus
and my great-grandfather died while my
grandfather was like six months old and
they were he had I think five brothers
and sisters and they were living it's I
mean it's the same old story that
everybody hears they were living in the
Lower East Side which is where all the
immigrants especially from Eastern
Europe that came through Ellis Island
that they all lived and it was like you
know basically one bedroom with five or
six kids and then my widowed
great-grandmother and my grandfather who
had they grew up with just absolutely
nothing and then he worked I remember my
grandfather grandpa already on my dad's
side insect he died when I was in second
grade but I remember being around first
grade or something and he was a great
golfer and I have a couple of his
hole-in-one statues and they in the
green room over there and I remember he
was teaching me how to golf and I
remember him once telling me he bought
me a golf club like a little kids golf
club and I remember him once telling me
that his first job was for 25 cents an
hour
so he grew up in abject poverty with
parents that were you know from from
another country first-generation
immigrants and was was lower class then
he worked really hard became a
lithographer my grandma Minnie who he
eventually married was the first person
in my family to go to college on either
side and then she ended up being a
typing teacher in Brooklyn but they
became sort of they were sort of lower
middle class to middle class then my
parents moved on from that and became
middle-class to - upper middle class I'm
doing okay now like it's the great
American story that it doesn't matter
whether you're Italian or Jewish or
Irish or Latino or black or white or
whatever it is it's like we all have
these stories in our families and I
wanted to sort of illustrate that
because I think one of the things that
we're fighting right now is there is a
feeling out there that somehow this this
experiment of America is somehow wrong
or or or is a bust or we should feel
guilty about it or something like that
and and I like calling it an experiment
which is a phrase that I got from Dennis
Prager actually who I've interviewed
here many times and I've done a couple
videos for Prager you because all
America is really is an experiment like
we're testing this thing out can people
live with with maximum freedoms can we
have a country that welcomes people that
that they can bring all of their talents
and skills and traditions and ethnic
backgrounds and cultural backgrounds and
fit into the tapestry of America while
still respecting our freedoms we've done
it here that melting pot better than any
country in the history of the world and
I think we don't step back to be
appreciative of that so as I was writing
this and learning more I mean this was
truly a learning process I did
ancestry.com which is one of the
sponsors by the way of our of our
podcast I think you go to ancestry.com
slash Rubin I but I did it in the midst
of all this because I wanted to find out
more about my family tree to find out
more about what my answers to ancestors
went through so that I could be a guy
that sits in his garage talking to a
camera about freedom I mean that's
pretty [ __ ] spectacular it's it's
it's incredible it's unimaginable I
don't think any of my grandparents on
either side could could possibly imagine
that this is real it's it's just it's
just incredible so
what are we doing here I'm gonna do a
couple radio resets while we're doing it
go - don't burn this book dot-com and
every single book that you buy today
once you're there you can click on the
button and you can buy the book on
Amazon or Barnes & Noble indie bound com
Apple books whatever it is you get your
receipt email - you forward that to bolt
forward that - don't burn this book at P
R H calm penguin Random House dot-com
and your names obviously in there just
include your address I will sign as I'm
doing right now I'm gonna sign a book
plate for you and you can put that in
your book and and we're all ready I mean
the numbers seem incredibly good from
what I'm seeing already we're climbing
up all these these Amazon charts and you
know the book is not even out for a
couple months which is which is pretty
awesome and and as I said you know I'm
in the editing process now so I will not
be editing during August which actually
I think is perfect because I've given
this thing my my heart and soul over the
last couple of months and I really do
need a break you know not only I need
like a like a mental break just to not
think about all of these things you know
what I mean it's like light life has
been very good to me the last couple
years have been great we've we built
this because of you guys right like
we're fully fan funded because of you
I'm not beholding to a company or a
person or anything I just do what I
think is right our team is expanding
we're trying to figure out ways to grow
and grow oh I don't want to fully give
this away but we're bringing somebody on
the team in September that is gonna be
big it is a it's a it's a blue check
verified person now that's all I'm gonna
say about it now so it's it's someone
legit that you all know that's gonna be
a new part of what we're doing here
that's gonna be in September and we have
a couple announcements actually in
September coming so here we go in
September so I'll be back on September
3rd as I said and we will be making at
least one Big Show announcement that
very day I can't say more right now but
we will be doing that and I also want to
say something about I've teased this a
little bit
but in the course of the last couple
months when when Jordan Peterson and
then Sam Harris and I when we all left
patreon because of the sargon of akkad
ding you know I had no idea we deleted
our our patreon account and we were
making it was something like 70% of our
monthly budget that goes to producing
this show was on patreon and we deleted
it I voluntarily deleted it and we moved
everybody over to Dave Rubin comm and we
had no idea you know crowdfunding there
if it was gonna work or whatever not
only did it work we ended up actually
making more because one of the things
that I write about in this book is I
think there's a bravery deficit in the
world people are afraid to step up and I
think there's very good reasons and I
get into those reasons too because the
mob the mob just destroys people it's
just like this endless you know what the
mob is like is the is like the nothing
from never ending story you remember the
never ending story it's just this
amorphous black cloud that just destroys
everything in its path and in this is
pretty fitting and I write about this
but in the neverending story you know
what has to beat the nothing is the
human imagination in the book it's the
in the movie it's the it's the
imagination of a child and I think that
that's what we need right now we need a
rebirth of imagination and I'm starting
to see lots of seeds about that I'm very
enthused about actually so I'm signing
books
oh so anyway within all of this not only
did we figure out this deal that I'll
announce in September I just can't say
more now but wrote the book did the show
every week which I still think is pretty
damn good you guys are still digging it
and that's great but I also started a
tech company in the midst of this
because the patreon thing happened and
as you know it was like suddenly like
there were all these issues about the
platforming and censorship and payment
processors and all of these things so I
also started a tech company we got some
nice VC I don't touch a dime of that
that goes to to paying the the project
managers and the engineers and all that
stuff and we're building out something
that I hope to launch in beta also on
September 3rd my guys are not gonna be
happy at me for saying that but that's
what I hope to happen on September 3rd
and of course if you're a subscriber now
at Dave Rubin calm slash donate you will
get first access to that I'm not asking
anyone to donate right now I'm just
saying that we're
the people that have been with us the
longest are gonna be the people that
we're gonna count on to help us you know
work out the kinks and all that stuff so
there's just there's just a lot going on
and that all kind of leads me to two why
I'm doing the off-the-grid thing and I
will be challenging some public people I
think Bridgette fed is he who I had on
the show a couple months ago who's a
great writer and comedian I think she's
gonna join me for all of August off the
grid and I'm gonna challenge a couple
other people but as I said I hope maybe
you guys can do it just in your own way
whatever that is like I get it most
people need to have a phone on them and
for me not having directions is gonna be
the craziest part I have GPS in my car
so I'll be ok with that
but I have a terrible sense of direction
so just like wandering around will be
tough but even like trying to meet up
meet somebody at a restaurant and it's
they're five minutes late you don't have
a phone or you're just gonna stand on
the corner like a schmuck like it's
gonna be it's gonna be something but I
want my I want my brain to experience
that I can tell you after doing it last
year like just my sense of patience and
calmness and and time time felt longer
actually so I'm really looking forward
to it and I think I kind of deserve it
after after all this this craziness it's
all good alright let me read off some
names to you guys because I see that
you're still buying as we're talking
it's don't burn this book calm and then
forward your receipt which you'll get
immediately we're regardless of where
you buy it you just forward your receipt
to don't burn this book at prh calm and
I'm gonna sign it for you right now oh
by the way I didn't even say this the
whole time sorry here's what we'll do
also I will gladly take Q&A right now so
we will do live Q&A so if you buy the
book just include a question forward the
receipt just include a question up top
and I'll answer some questions live so
don't burn this book at prh calm you
have to forward your receipt put a
question in there I will answer some
questions shout outs to Barbara Mike
Gregory Garrett Adam Vaughan Erica mark
Geena Erin Robert Jeff Bradford Jacob
Zander Terry Joshua Vincent Paul Morgan
kay andrew evan matt richard nicholas
chad Rick Michael Derek Jason Marty I'll
see if I can do more of those later that
was that was a good crew getting a
little head rush oh man they're really
coming in right now okay so yeah so if
you buy the book Barnes and Noble
Apple book etc Indy bound forward the
receipt put a question in there and my
guys are gonna throw me some questions
live in a little bit so one of the
things that I will tell you a little bit
about sort of the adventure about all
this because a lot of times people say
to me when I when I do road gigs people
will will say to me that you know
they'll say nice things like you're a
good interviewer or you know enjoy the
show
that sort of thing but they do often
want to know more about me a little bit
more about my adventure and all that so
I do talk about sort of my professional
adventure and all this as well so I'll
give you guys just a little bit of that
right now because a lot of it's been
it's been rattling around my head as I
wrote this so for those of you that
don't know so I'm a true New Yorker
really I was born in Brooklyn I grew up
in Long Island I lived in New York City
most of my adult life and I went to SUNY
Binghamton which is State University of
New York at Binghamton for college and
then it was in February of 2013 that I
moved to Los Angeles so it's kind of
funny because I know that actually these
days probably most of my fan base or
most of the people that appreciate what
I do are probably in the middle of the
country if we're just looking at this
from an American perspective but I've
actually only lived in New York in LA so
when people talk about like the coasts
and the coastal elites and the big
cities and whatever it's like I'm from
those two places I have only lived only
lived in New York and Los Angeles and
for whatever reason the things that I
care about seem to really resonate with
with people in the middle of the country
and that's what one of the reasons that
doing the tour of with Jordan was so
great because there were so many cities
that I had never been to States that I
had never I had never been to nebraska I
had never been to Missouri I had never
been to Utah and going to all of these
places and then you know one of the
other things that was cool is that
during the during the tour if I had a
night off or if we got into a city a day
early or something like that I would
book a stand-up gig in in the local city
and we sold out I think pretty much
every show that I did usually a couple
hundred seats and we were at Improv zall
over the place and a bunch of different
clubs and then sometimes
would either fly in or depending on
where we were I would bring like one of
the intellectual dark web people so when
we were at the DC improv I had christina
hoff sommers come onstage at the phoenix
improv I had Eric Weinstein fly in Brett
Weinstein joining me for a couple of
them up in Seattle and a few others and
then the craziest one though was at I
think it's wise crackers in Salt Lake
City it's great great great comedy club
probably about three four hundred seats
it was a madhouse
the crowd was unbelievable I was just
feeling it from the beginning and I
don't do stand-up in a in a traditional
way at all like I get up there I got a
couple of jokes but I'm just messing
around the crowd it's extremely
politically incorrect um you know I mock
identity politics and I'm throwing
t-shirts out there to people that are
doing crazy stuff it's it's like a
three-ring circus and it's just and it's
just real and different every time
anyway so I usually do about 45 minutes
to an hour and then I bring on the
guests so for that night most of the
audience had guessed who it was because
I was in Salt Lake City and everyone
knew that Jordan Peterson was performing
for the twelve rules for life the next
night but Jordan came on stage and it
was for me it was it was the best night
of the whole tour because Jordan got up
there and it's not like he told jokes up
there but we just kind of told some
stories and we kind of ripped on each
other he made fun of me a little bit and
I made fun of him and it was just it was
just a great night so anyway I mentioned
all this because just getting out there
and meeting you guys over the last year
it's it's so different than what people
see online so it's like people pretend
that that online is just real and it's
like if you get out there and meet real
people it's all good like everyone that
comes up to me in real life at an
airport or at the supermarket or at the
freaking bowling alley like people are
great they really are great it is it is
I don't think I've ever had someone come
up to me and say something mean I wasn't
IKEA a couple weeks ago and there was a
guy with green hair kind of pudgy guy
like leaning against the wall and he was
kind of looking at me like this and I
was like all right I get it I get it so
a boy that's all right you don't like me
that's okay
but but the point is that people are
good and I think what I've tried to do
with this show and what I tried to do
with the book is show that what those
political differences that we have are
they seem huge they seem they seem
monumental and they seem insurmountable
but you want to live in a country that
people have different differences of
opinions right you want to live in a
country like that what you don't want is
people to be allowed to impose their
opinions on you and I tried in this book
to lay out the best ideas that will sort
of allow maximum freedom for as many
people as possible now I do that of
course through the lens of classical
liberalism and by the way there's such
an interesting thing happening in the
world right now where there's all these
articles being written about post
liberalism is liberalism at its and like
is the end of liberalism just what the
social justice warriors have brought
upon us and there's an interesting
argument for that that liberalism in and
of itself isn't enough like secular
liberalism isn't enough in and of itself
to stand up to this woke progressive
monster and I think there's an
interesting argument there i push back
on that a bit and I sort of expand on it
a bit and that you know conservatives if
conservatives look generally at the
world through a bit of a religious lens
right so they look at the world that
there there are more there is a moral
code and rules outside outside of you as
a human being right and then our
founders in many ways they were sort of
a blend at some level between what you
would say is a classical liberal
individual rights limited government and
then also had some conservative piece
there because they all would talk about
freedom from religion and freedom of
religion while saying that the rights
that were guaranteed to us in the
Constitution the Bill of Rights were
god-given rights meaning they come from
something before us and and so I really
get into that which i think is one of
the most fascinating topics it's exactly
what Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris were
debating about during those debates the
sort of nature of truth and where does
morality come from and can there be such
a purely secular morality now of course
I believe that purely secular people can
be moral and religious people can be
amoral and all of that but how do you
build societies around that where does
that place liberalism right now and what
I also hope for and what I see all the
time and I get a ton of hate for this is
that modern conservatives have proven to
me time and time again to be extremely
tolerant and
tolerant and liberal liberal actually
and is in a certain sense they've been
shown to me that look something like gay
marriage conservatives don't care about
it anymore and that and a conservative
principle of limited government and
getting the government out of your life
now they may not like it from a
religious perspective and I can actually
respect that which is why I can sit in
my own home where I'm married to a man
with Ben Shapiro who has a religious
perspective on gay marriage which by the
way was the perspective that almost
everybody had in the world until about
ten years ago if the perspective that
Barack Obama ran on first time around
right but what I want to see out of the
Conservatives and what I'm seeing and
what I talked about in this book is I
think conservatism doesn't have to give
up any of the things it believes but
carve out a little space for the the
Liberals that are trying to find a new
home try to find a place for the the
secularists the atheists don't make
everything about what you want the world
to be religiously sort of go go to those
true conservative values and this I'm
just completely fascinated by this new
alignment because I'm seeing it in real
life I'm seeing it in real life I when I
do stand-up I usually polled the
audience I do some funny stuff about you
know how many conservatives how many
libertarians how many progressives
there's always one guy that can barely
clap you know and the rest of it and
what I see is all these people that have
wildly different opinions on taxes on
abortion on death penalty all of these
things when I go up there and you know
most of the audience usually I'd say
something about like 50% of the audience
usually applauds for conservative then
and then I would say another like 30%
applauds for libertarian and there's a
lot of like overlap on that right and
the libertarians I would say at this
point are like my true people because I
just really believe in live and let live
like that's that's really what it all
whittles down to for me but what I see
is that people actually love Believe It
or Not guys they love being in a room
with other people and looking around and
going oh there's a black guy that
happens to be conservative or there's a
conservative that happens to be black
and there's an older white woman who's a
liberal
and no one cares about any of that like
even they have to frame it in that
stupid way and that's kind of the way I
do these shows so I will get back out on
tour by the way
stand up we'll start that again in
September and then when the book comes
out in April we're gonna do a big book
tour and we're trying to figure that out
and you will see how Jordan may or may
not be involved depending on what's
going on with him and just again I just
Jordan if you're watching this I cannot
cannot possibly thank you enough for
just including me in everything that you
did in the last year and letting be part
of that magical tour because it led to
this it led to this right like that's
that's pretty incredible so what are we
doing right now people everyone that
buys my book
don't burn this book calm which went on
sale today and is that Amazon Barnes and
Noble indeed bound Apple books and more
go to don't burn this book calm click
one of those links buy the book forward
your receipt over to don't burn this
book at prh dot-com and and we're gonna
sign we when I say we I mean me I am
going to sign a book plate for you right
now the first thousand were numbered
we're way past that point at this point
but I'm just gonna keep going here and
I'll sign as many thousand as we sell
today I will gladly do it I'm thrilled
to do it actually okay let's see I see a
couple questions here do you think
you'll have Colin Moriarty back on the
show anytime soon absolutely he's always
welcome to come back I tried to have
dinner with him last week but he wasn't
able to do it Colin you know he's
another example of one of these people
that gets thrust into the culture war
and I I think I left this chapter and
actually we had we had moved a couple
things around and as we begun the
editing process but one of the things I
talk about is how it's it's not these
people are not special or spectacular
that that you know of for doing these
things you know one of the things that
put Jordan on the map was talking about
bill c-17 in Canada about where the
government was gonna find people about
using trans people's preferred pronouns
and that's that you know they wanted to
compel speech which is ridiculous
Jordan you said I'm not going to do that
I'm not against trans people but then of
course he gets label to transfer but big
at home
football that Brett Weinstein says I am
NOT going to not go to campus one day as
a white person because you don't want me
to if students of color don't want to go
to campus one day to honor whatever it
is that they want honor that's fine
that's gone on for many years but Brett
protested segregating campus by the
color of people's skin and then he gets
thrust into it so Jordan gets thrust in
Brett gets thrust in James two more who
I mentioned before he gets thrust in
because Google asks him to go to a
diversity training session and write his
feelings about it which is exactly what
he does they fire him Lindsey Shepherd
who I talked about earlier all of these
people so Colin has another interesting
one Colin's a video game guy right and
he basically I had him on here while he
was basically a gamer he had a lot of
libertarian beliefs he's a great guy
just a genuine good decent human being
and he's a video game guy he sends out a
tweet on I think it was on International
Women's Day and it was something like
finally some peace and quiet in hashtag
International Women's Day and it the
tweet blows up the outrage mob goes
after him and was it the International
Business Times my guys can check on this
I think it was the International
Business Times wrote an article about
Colin Moriarty's racist tweet there was
literally nothing about race in there
and he was writing it by the way while
he was in bed with his girlfriend so the
people that were saying he was
misogynistic his girlfriend was in bed
with him but then he gets thrust into it
he then of course you know what happens
was finally I was able to get a contact
of somebody at International Business
Times I hope that's the correct one and
they were able to retract the the piece
that he didn't write anything racist but
you know that's a day later once stuff
is already out there in the ethernet and
and it's like you know out there in the
ether that's funny the ethernet it's out
there in the ether on the internet and
then you know it gets in people's
Wikipedia pages and all that so so many
of us have just been kind of thrust into
this thing but I don't think any of us
inherently are something special other
than we're just doing what we what we're
what we think is right that really is it
okay let's see new orders orders that
were just taken here I'll just do a
couple that we're just taking because
we've been getting
all day but these were just taken during
the livestream Jeff Clark Thailand
Dwayne Colson Joshua Jerome Brad Molly
Kerry Zachary John Douglas R Lee
Gary Brian Josh Laszlo Aubrey Samuel
Garrett AJ Joe Jacob Matt Andy Marcy Rio
Chad Paul Spencer Charles Jovita and
Chlo or Chloe
thank you guys we're signing every copy
for you and remember if you go to don't
burn this book com forward us your
receipt I'm gonna sign one of these book
plates for you you can put it in the
book and if you're getting the digital
copy by the way which is out right now
you can you know you can put it on the
back of your Kindle or whatever or you
can slap it on your laptop or wherever
else and if you email us at don't burn
this book at prh calm you can put a
question in there so just put a question
for me right now live above your receipt
and I will gladly answer some questions
so I see a couple a couple more in here
so are you and Jordan in Utah looking
forward to reading the book it was wise
guys not wise crackers ah that's what
happens the comedy club was called wise
guys not wise crackers but I'm sure
there's a comedy club called wise
crackers yeah I hope you enjoy the show
it was just it was just a great what a
great night it was just a great night
another question how does one get out of
the audience and into the effort so you
know this is one of the questions that I
get more than anything else when I speak
at colleges or just any events that I do
I was at a young Americans for liberty
event in San Jose last week I was at and
a RI event in Cleveland couple weeks
before that that was we aired that one
actually on the channel that was with
neuron Brook and a couple other people
are talking about tech censorship and
all that but one of the things people
keep asking me and I and and by the way
when I was on tour we toured and people
asked this question of Jordan all the
time and I was in charge for those of
you that never got to see one of the
live shows the way the show went with
Jordan was that I would do 10 or 15
minutes up top just make everybody laugh
have fun look around the room realize
that you're not in a room full of racist
bigoted homophobes these are good people
the audience's they would say it's all
angry
man you'd look around the room and it
was usually like 60/40 male-to-female
but sometimes probably 50/50 if not more
there'd be black people white people
trans people Muslim people nobody cared
about any of that nonsense so and I'd
make silly lobster jokes and the rest of
it just get the crowd going for Jordan
it's not my night I was purely there
just to just to basically just toss it
up to him so he could just knock it out
of the park right that was it and and
that's what I did and so I would do that
then Jordan would give a different I
mean people I say this and people can't
really understand how just staggeringly
incredible this is the guy gave a
different lecture every single night I
never saw the same lecture twice never
saw the same lecture twice I could see
on nights and this is this is how how
this guy's mind works I could see on
nights where he would start thinking
through an idea on stage and he would
sort of take it to exactly where he felt
he couldn't take it any longer so he
would like stretch out the idea as long
as possible and then the next night
after having a night to sleep on it to
think about it travel he would take it a
little bit further and the way he would
he would use a story to explain that
where he would say that when he was when
he was younger and and his daughter
Mikayla would be climbing a tree in
front of the house that he would watch
her and you know one day she could
stretch her leg out a little bit to get
to another branch and then she would
pull back and then the next day she'd
try it again but couldn't quite get
there but then over time to keep going
keep going and keep going and that was
what he was doing intellectually every
night so it was really great but the
question that we got all the time and
that I that I get at all these college
gigs is how do you get into the fight
and and that really in many ways is one
of the core points of this book because
as I said all of these people that you
know that you watch on YouTube or that
are slammed by the media or that are
misunderstood or D platformed or the
rest of it like most of these people are
not bad people and they're also not
exceptional people as I'm saying they're
just people doing what they think is
right but what they've done is for some
reason and I guess I guess I'm included
in this for some reason we were willing
to say what we think and I think that if
you start saying what you think
that you can have in an effect that you
cannot even imagine you can have an
immeasurably positive effect on the
world imagine if you started doing that
now I'm guessing if you're watching this
you're not an evil racist bigoted
homophobe you may have some libertarian
beliefs some classical liberal beliefs
you may have some out outside the box
political beliefs yet Michael malice who
I've had it here all the time who's
basically an anarchist I love the guy
he's a truly unique political thinker
some of his stuff is sort of off the
rails but it's great to think about he's
a true character right whatever your
thoughts are imagine if you started
speaking up more it seems to me that
right now what's happening and this is
one of the things I talk about a lot is
that one of the reason the mob just
keeps in Crowe Qing is because it's
preying on the fear of good people to be
quiet and I think what's happening is
that good people think oh this thing's
just gonna pass you know like that
somehow if I'm just quiet enough long
enough that these really awful
authoritarian forces and and this this
socialist movement that's growing and
the ideas of collectivism and this
anti-capitalist hatred and this hatred
of of white men and of Christians and of
Jews and all of this stuff that it'll
just kind of go away but actually your
acquiescence feeds it and it feeds it
more and more and more and I really
believe if more of you whatever that
means to you whatever that means like if
that means that you know you're you're
in a relationship and your spouse is
constantly on the attack about politics
or or whatever it is whatever is
happening culturally and you just you
just turn the other cheek all the time
because you think it's just the easier
way you're you're giving space for bad
ideas to grow and I think that that's
how we got into this situation too many
people workout by the false cries of
racism and bigotry and all of that stuff
it was a it was a really effective but
truly evil tactic that that mostly the
progressive left used and embraced and
imp and weaponized to silence a lot of
good people and it takes it takes
growing some balls to get up and start
saying what you think but imagine if you
started doing that maybe you would
inspire
somewhat one of your co-workers or your
buddy or your brother or your cousin to
do it too and then if more of us just
start doing it I'm not seeing I'm not
trying to I'm not saying shout people
down or deep platform people don't be as
bad as them I mean that's the other part
of it right you one of the ways I think
truly that we get out of this is that
for this new alliance that I think is a
sort of center-right sort of freedom
liberty based alliance that has you know
some conservative elements and some
libertarian elements and the disaffected
lefties in the rest of it all that thing
really has to do is just be a little bit
better as we as we're watching the
progressives decimate what's left of the
decent liberals and there's almost none
of them left right we're in we're in
order 66 land at this point right we're
the last Jedi are strong throughout the
galaxy and they're being hunted down by
their own troops I mean that really is
what's happening here we're watching the
left sort of just eat all of its good
people and that's why even tonight
within the hour I think there is a
democratic debate and all its gonna be
is a litany of identity politics and and
class warfare and and hating white men
and donde la biblioteca me amigo es
Grande Don Mills apotheosis Blanco I
mean just this this ridiculous pandering
to people and speaking languages I mean
that that thing is just the absolute
craziest from the last one that they
started all speaking in Spanish just you
know it's it's so pandering it's it's
just awful imagine in the 1930s right
we're 1920's 1930's 1940s we get all
these immigrants right from all over
Europe and imagine if the presidential
candidates had gotten up there you know
and been like oh I see we've got a lot
of new Irish citizens I'm gonna give us
a lolly and a potato all of you it's
like what we would think that that's
either racist or ridiculous or at best
the worst pandering nonsense you know
it's a spicy meatball everybody isn't
gonna get a meatball for all of my
Italian uh friends you know it's like
what are what are we letting these guys
get away with you know it's like yeah
like you guys gonna get up there schmuck
like we got like Jackie Mason so all the
Jews are gonna get a good four filter
fish but it's like why why do we put up
with this nonsense but there's a reason
we put up with it because the good
liberals don't know how to fight that
stuff and you can see so someone like
Biden who should be mostly a decent kind
of old-school liberal moderate he's just
being eaten alive right now because he
doesn't have enough to stand on to fight
this so they they just call him a racist
and it just counts you know come on out
he's a racist well I guess he's racist
well it's craziness people what the hell
are we doing here
don't burn this book calm it is my new
book it is officially up for pre-sale
today that is right I've been writing
this thing for months I'm thrilled to
finally be able to share it with you I
am signing book plates that you guys
will be able to put in the book I am
signing every single freaking copy that
we sell today whether you buy it on
amazon barnes & noble indie bound apple
book wherever it is and if you forward
the receipt so once you buy the book if
you forward the receipt to don't burn
this book at prh dot-com we will send
the signed plate to you here I'll even
sign one right now this could be yours
right there that could be yours and not
only that but you can also ask questions
in there so just put a question in the
forwarded email and I've got an iPad
here
that's the iPad and holy cow we're right
now we are number 35 in the bestseller
list on Amazon in all books right now no
one even has the book yet that's pretty
freaking amazing you guys are incredible
truly incredible like my whole life is
coming together this like this is this
like this is your life happening all at
the same moment right now you guys are
absolutely absolutely incredible
all right shout-out Cynthia Wesley Peter
Emily Joshua hunter John Paul David case
David Lauren Michael Nicholas Justin
Paulette William Alissa Andrew
Christopher Eric's out Kyle Stephanie
Ben Courtney Jade it's Glen Jennifer
Adam James Luke Brenda Daniel Rob I'll
get to you next we'll start it Rob guys
after that one holy cow all right let's
see here we go I'll answer some of the
questions so are you Jordan or any of
the others from the IDW coming to
Connecticut any time soon also can my
dog Val get a shout-out on the live
stream from that was from Zach all right
Valley you just got a shout out actually
real quick I'll give you guys an update
on our dog Emma so I think most of you
guys know at this point so Emma who was
a rescue from Hurricane Katrina in New
Orleans back in summer of 2005 I got her
in June of 2006 you know the dogs had
been dispersed all over the place all
over the country she was very very sick
from drinking oil and living through
whatever she had to live through there
she actually gave birth during the
hurricane they found her in a little box
at st. Bernard's parish which I just
found out about I'll tell you why in a
sec and she was nursing the puppies were
healthy the puppies the three puppies
got adopted immediately we we got Emma
and now at the time she's had three
names just bear with me if you've heard
this story before she's had three names
cuz she had a name in New Orleans that
we don't know cuz she had a collar with
no tags then at the Humane Society they
named her Paisley and then when we got
her we named her Emma now I got her in
June on June 22nd actually of 2006 which
was about you know that's what's eight
nine months after the hurricane and she
was finally had been brought back to
health and she was able to be adopted
and we got her and I was walking her in
Central Park first day I had her and
this woman came up to me and said is
that Paisley from the Humane Society and
I said yeah and she said this is her son
Bernard and Bernard and Emma got
together and they sniffed but like only
a mother and son could and then Bernard
ended up moving and then we lost contact
for like 13 years and then get this so
then a few months ago about five months
ago now actually we found out that Emma
has pretty severe bladder cancer and
she's actually doing great the
veterinary oncologist gave her two to
five months
she's now passed the five month mark
she's having a little bit arthritis now
that's actually bothering her more than
the cancer but we changed we basically
just changed her diet it's all organic
home-cooked food and some CBD and some
other stuff but no conventional medicine
no no chemo none of that stuff and
anyway I'm sure many of you have seen I
had posted long Twitter threads at
pictures with her over the years and you
know I don't really remember my life
before her and I remember nights in New
York City when I lived in this shitty
little crappy apartment on on Amsterdam
and the heat would go out for days in
the middle of a blizzard and there would
be nights I would be snuggle
with Emma Jesper warm and anyway sent
this out and then long story short we
got in touch with the woman that owned
Bernard Bernards owner and Saint
Bernards church that's how he got named
Bernard and it turns out that she lives
only like 15 minutes away from us here
in Los Angeles and we've gotten them
together a couple times we did it on
Mother's Day and I've posted some
pictures on my Instagram with that so
you can check it out it's Instagram calm
slash Rubin report has just been a great
story so happy to give a shout out to
Val and any of the dogs out there okay
all right you know what I'll do a couple
more names and then we'll we'll jump
back in Rob Marielle and Jenny Rob again
with two B's Rayanne nicholas kevin
michael christopher star Michael Chris
Michael Vesper Colleen Haig Lucas Alex
Barrie Katie Chris Jared Jake - Ari
Michelle Pamela of Cody Erin and
Nicholas all right you guys can delete
those I'll keep going in a second I'm
gonna sign some more some more books
here I'm doing a thousand things at once
what the hell are we doing here people
don't burn this book calm my book it's
out for pre-sale we've got we've got pre
advanced messages on the back already
they call it advanced advanced notice
basically from Ben Shapiro and from
Peter teal and from Larry King and from
Tucker Carlson and you know these are
all people who have orbited my world
that I have some political disagreements
with some agreements but as I said these
new these new alliances and these these
new tents are going up right now and
it's like I think it's on all of us you
know it's it's so interesting because so
many people at least at the social-media
level of it seem like they're so
depressed about the way the world is and
everything's awful and it's just
terrible and uh it's like no if you if
you actually step back a little bit you
will see something incredible going on
there are so many more people engaged
right now so many more people thinking
about what they think and why they think
it and that's why that's why I'm writing
this book and that's why the the
subtitle is thinking for yourself in an
age of unreason because I'm actually
then this was we had a whole bunch of
discussions with the the publishers on
this but I'm
really not this is not a book where I'm
telling you what to believe politically
there are actual moments in this where
there's a chapter actually where I lay
out I take like most of the the
hot-button issues of the day so say
abortion and death penalty and taxes and
gay marriage and foreign policy and all
of these things and and I lay out my
beliefs on them and and through the lens
of classical liberalism which is the
lens that I look at things but I'm not
telling you that you have to believe
these things I actually make the
argument so I can a case of abortion for
example I make the argument that
absolutely there are good people on both
sides I don't think it's the case that
people on the right hate women and I
don't think it's the case that people on
the Left hate babies and that what are
the ways that we can talk about an issue
like this while respecting the general
beliefs of Rights for the individual and
why abortion of course is such a complex
one on this is because generally people
on the left put more of the well they
don't believe in the individual as much
but in this case they put they believe
that it's the individual meaning the
woman's right to choose where the people
on the right believe that the the fetus
has a right to life as well and it's
just a different way of looking at the
world and that's what we have to bridge
and you want to live in a country with
people where you can really argue those
things what I find interesting about the
abortion debate and I referenced this in
the book is that I find people on the
right so the pro-life people are far
more willing to engage in good faith
than people and left now that obviously
is a theme a lot politically these days
but I've had many people in this very
studio who are more than happy to debate
and not even debate just have an honest
open conversation with pro-choice people
and even though I consider myself
progressively pro-choice I see people on
the right trying to reach out it's very
rare that you see someone on the Left
that's really willing to engage with
someone on the right if if you're
watching this and you know of somebody
if you've got somebody that's that's a
published author or you know an
outspoken online personality with a
decent following that that is willing to
engage and not call people names and all
those things like I'd love to set some
of those debates up I'd love to have
those conversations but what I try to
lay out are just the basic guidelines
for you to
for you to know how to think about the
issues and if you come to a different
conclusion than I do then then more
power to you I suppose all right
don't burn this book calm I am signing
every single copy that we sell today
till midnight tonight I believe and
you're gonna go to don't burn this book
calm where you can buy the book then
forward your receipt to don't burn this
book at prh calm penguin Random House
dot-com and then you can actually put a
question for me that I'll read on the
livestream right now if you've got some
questions oh I see we got a couple more
here and I'll answer the question live
right there and what am i doing I'm
signing book plates people book that was
a terrible signature I'm not doing that
one that one's going away here we go
I'll make that one up for you I'll give
you a primo Dave Rubin signature that's
nice right there okay there you go
here we go I'm gonna do some new orders
Ryan Brad Joseph VIN Connor Matthew
Richard Nathaniel Corey Nathan Beth
Scott Jack Luke hope Lance Brad James
Bradley William Daniel Lisa Philip
Ricardo Patrick Lonnie Roxanna Josh
Howard Camille Elena
Todd Colby Jordan Creighton Ian Melanie
Lori Alexandria Charles Adam Robert
Darlene Bruce Scott Steve Donovan Janet
Kyle Kevin kiss Chris Sir Robert Brian
Cooke Michael Gabriel Matilda and an
Andrew thank you for buying the book
appreciate it
okay let's see oh here's this is this is
a really interesting question how can we
teach American children the
entrepreneurial mindset on a large scale
well I think the first thing that you
have to teach them basically is
understand why this thing here in
America why Western civilization that is
rooted in the individual individual
rights that we should have individual
rights where no group has a right but
you as an individual should be treated
equally regardless of your sex gender
race color ethnicity any of those things
that's what we have in the United
we haven't always had it right we had
slavery we don't have it anymore
that is fantastic women could not vote
they can vote now that is spectacular
gay people could not get married they
can now that is wonderful
the arc of justice of true justice not
social justice which is neither social
nor justice the arc of true justice has
always bent towards more freedom that is
what we have done here in the United
States that's why people now are dying
to get into the United States no one is
dying to get out when Trump even says to
people that they should get out if they
don't like it here now you may not like
the way he says it you may not
appreciate who he's saying it to or any
of the political nonsensical
machinations of the day but it's an
interesting point if we're so horrible
if we're if the patriarchy and
capitalism and our healthcare and all
these things it's so freakin terrible
then why do you guys want to let
everybody in why would you subject
people to the horrors the abject horrors
of the United States I I just don't know
why so what can we do to get people into
more into the entrepreneurial spirit I
can tell you this I I mean I've said
this before but I can tell you that one
of the one of the really cool things
about my adventure in the last couple
years is that and I and I write about
this in the book as well as that so I
did stand-up in New York for about 12
years and that came with all of the the
struggles of being a comic and the good
parts about it and you know getting past
the clubs and handing out tickets I used
to hand out we used to call it barking I
would stand in Times Square and hand out
tickets sometimes two hours a night six
nights a week rain nor sleet nor snow no
matter what the weather we'd be out
there just to perform in front of a
couple people and I started some comedy
clubs we did some really great
entrepreneurial things with some of the
other comics but I did that for a while
eventually I had a show on Sirius XM for
a while that eventually got me to the
Young Turks then very briefly when I
left them I left for riot which was an
internet startup and we just quickly
kind of realized even though I liked
everybody there we kind of realized we
were going in different directions
that's when Larry King and or a TV
contacted me and that's when the show
really started exploding so I know the
date I believe it's September 9th 2015
was that first interview that we did
with Sam Harris I think that's the day
we posted it I think we shot it the day
before
and and that's really when the show blew
up and then from aura TV that's when I
realized the show was growing faster
than the network itself and we decided
to leave which we had a lot to do with
the conversation that I had on the show
with Joran Brooke from the iron ran
Institute he was talking about rational
self-interest and taking control of your
own destiny and believing in yourself as
an individual and I realized wow that's
what I want to do I want to go
independent that's when we launched on
patreon in June of 2016 which you know
now it sounds like a long time ago but
we patreon was just brand new at the
moment of people where he was mostly
video gamers on air now now a lot of
people aren't on there but there were
none of the political people on there
and I was the first one and we kind of
broke the ice for everybody and then a
whole bunch of people went on and now a
whole bunch of people have gone off but
then from there we went independent I
didn't know if it was gonna work or not
we stayed on patreon for what you know
two to three years then when this thing
happened in December with sargon of
akkad and him getting D platformed I
left patron again to go fully
independent on our own website and do
all our funding ourselves and and along
the road we were able to buy this house
because of you guys we built this
incredible studio I mean everybody comes
in to my garage this is my freaking
garage everyone that comes in here I
will never forget it when Tucker Carlson
walked into that studio he opens up the
door at the garage door right there so
when you walk into my house the garage
is immediately to the right so the way
we have it and I'll do some
behind-the-scenes things in the fall
giving you guys a little more tour of we
have a green room over there where you
know guests have a fridge and coffee and
soda and videogames and water and there
I've got some Star Wars stuff in there
and whatever that's just for everybody
relax and chill out right over here is
our control room that's where my team
stays during the show and Aaron our
director and all these the rest of my
guys that are taking notes and doing
whatever it is that they're doing and
anyway Tucker Carlson who is you know
the star of the highest rated show on
Fox News I think he might be the
highest-paid person in cable TV I'm not
sure I go on a show now basically once a
week I don't get paid for that I'm happy
to I'm happy to do it they never asked
me before for any pre advanced questions
we go on live I say whatever I want I'd
be happy to do that on CNN or MSNBC too
but they don't invite me
but in any event tucker opened the door
or actually david open the door for
Tucker Tucker walks in and he looks up
and we have nice big 15-foot high
ceilings so we've been able to build a
really cool lighting grid I'll show you
guys some behind-the-scenes stuff some
other time and this is this is absolute
Pro Studio here and Tucker I'm sitting
here he walks in as a yeah you know it
and he was like holy [ __ ] man you have
done it right and to hear that and I
hear that message more and more and more
from different guests like we've built
something that is truly professional
here that I own and control and I relate
that back to your question about
entrepreneurialism which is those are
the stories that need to be heard you
know it I mean like that's I write about
that story in this book because I think
once you start seeing that there are
everything that's cool everything that's
cool whether it's music or comedy or art
or anything a physical structure that's
built that's really cool or a new car
that comes out as awesome these are
individual people that come together to
do something together and build
something cool it is so rarely the
government that does that now I'm not
saying there's no need for government
but it's it's the human spirit it's the
American spirit in this case and I think
we have to show people more of these
stories that you can go grab that dream
it's not a guarantee it's a dream but
all you call you can ask for is equal
rights man you just want equal rights
get me in here treat me equally it
doesn't mean people aren't gonna be mean
it doesn't mean someone grew up having
more and some of you up having less and
I got a limp and I got a lazy eye and
that that had to do we've all got [ __ ]
we've all got it but if you get out
there and give it your best shot I
actually believe good things can happen
and I consistently see it I consistently
see it because I go to shows where I
meet you know I do meet and greets after
and I meet people and then I see other
people start talking to each other you
know if there's a line let's say and I'm
talking to some people I'll see how to
corner my other people start talking
next thing you know people are going out
to drinks together sometimes I've gone
out to dinners with people after the
show like people want to find other
people to build something with to do
something entrepreneurial with so it's
it's actually a very cool thing don't
burn this book calm people
I am sai
every single copy that we sell today I
haven't signed any in the last few
minutes I am signing every single copy
that we sell today we're apparently
doing extremely well on Amazon right now
so I'm I'm thrilled about that if you
guys want to give me give me an update
on that that would be great so what
we're doing is I'm signing these book
plates you will be mailed this book
plate you can put it in your copy of
don't burn this book or if you get one
of digital copies you can put it on the
back here iPad or your computer or your
laptop or your you know your washing
machine whatever you'd like to do there
and yeah it's it's all good a lot of
good things happen in people okay here
I'll read off a couple names for you I'm
just going to do 10 this time because
I'm gonna give myself an aneurysm if I
keep doing it that way
tabatha may major Christians Stephen
Thomas Alyssa Eric Ross I think that's
to Eric Ross Marcy Gus Joshua all right
we'll stop there for now and don't
forget so once you go to don't burn this
book com order the book whether you want
to do it on Amazon Barnes & Noble indie
bound whatever you want to do Apple
books whatever it is then you forward
your receipt to don't burn this book at
PR H calm that's penguin Random House
dot-com and you can insert a question in
there and I will read your question live
I will gladly take your question right
now and and then we'll go from there
okay and actually speaking of questions
let me do that right Oh real quick so
right now so we've only sold the in the
the American rights to this book so I
see a lot of people are asking about the
international right because I know that
they were we've got I just did this tour
in Australia with Jordan and we were in
the UK and we were in Ireland and Norway
and Sweden and all these great places we
are currently right now they're
negotiating my guys are negotiating all
the international rights so I promise
you when when we get into each of these
countries we will do a full on book
signing thing again for all of you guys
I'm not doing this just for Americans
you know for those greedy Americans I
will do this for everybody apparently
some people in Canada have been going
into Amazon the American Amazon and
figuring it out that way I'm not telling
you to do anything just but I promise
you
every country that we get in I promise
you I will do one of these so you will
have an opportunity and eventually by
the way we will go on tour as well so
I'll probably be on tour in May and June
and we'll see who I want to bring on
tour with me and the rest of it maybe I
get Jordan Peterson to open for me now
that would be something but but at that
point I'll sign books and things in
person you know one of the reasons that
I really wanted to write the book was on
tour with Jordan I didn't have a book
right so you know all these people would
be coming a meet and greets after or
people coming up to me in the street and
they'd be like sign this book and I was
signing Jordan's book and I started
feeling guilty or sometimes I'd sign
other people's books or people would be
like you don't have a book you know can
you just sign my arm so so that was
another reason that I wanted to do it so
I promise you that we will do it
internationally but that's great that
we're doing so well on Amazon for now
without even the international sales so
a couple questions because if you buy
the book it don't burn this book calm
pick it up wherever you want to forward
the receipt to don't burn this book at
prh calm and then insert a question and
I will read a question live for you
right now I miss our old patreon chats
think you'll ever be able to do
something like that again so on patreon
one of the things that they had was a
chat function on the app where I could
just if I was at an airport or I just
had a few minutes I could just send push
notifications out to a couple of
thousand people and do a group chat
there I don't want to say too much about
this because my tech people won't be
thrilled but I told you before that we
that we started a tech company in the
last six months we are building
something seriously cool that I think
deals with so many of the DES
platforming issues that allows creators
to control their destiny more I just I
just can't say too much yet
but people that are subscribed at Dave
Rubin comm slash donate and I'm not
asking anyone to donate right now not
asking anyone to subscribe this is about
the book they will have first access to
the beta version of this which I think
will I'm hoping we can get this thing
out on September 3rd at least for the
initial people but certainly in the fall
and there's a lot of cool things
happening and I and and we'll see what
the feature set is that's pretty much as
much as I can say about that at the
moment do you think the Democrats will
have to have a Phoenix style rebirth
before they'll be in touch with the
general public again
do you think they will so this is a
great question this is and I write about
this in don't burn this book thinking
for yourself at an age of unreason by
Dave Rubin foreword by Jordan B Peterson
which you can buy it don't burn this
book calm I think you know I've talked
about this a little bit before like what
has to happen to the left what has to
happen to the Democrats what has to
happen to the Liberals as we watch the
progressives and the Democratic
socialists who are gonna drop the word
Democrat any day it's fairly obvious as
they veer off further and further off
the deep end and as they've ransacked
the party which I partly think is the
intention like I partly think that the
reason AOC and to leave and and Omar the
rest of them say these crazy things all
the time they know that's all nonsense
but they're trying to destroy the last
remnants of the Democratic Party so that
they can just take over the shell of it
now the question is well is that going
to happen and what does that become and
that would really be horrific and by the
way if you're if you're a standard
conservative or something you don't want
to see them completely implode and
really go off the deep end into like the
the true collectivist socialist
communist nonsense because even though
maybe that is what they are or something
like that like they're just becoming
themselves we I think we all in in a
pluralistic society where we've got
three hundred twenty some a million
people we want some sort of healthy
balance right you want something that
makes sure both sides don't go too off
into the extreme so on the right let's
say you want to make sure that you don't
want the people who want the government
to never help anybody under any
circumstances whatsoever which that's
sort of taking liberal libertarianism to
its nth degree which is why I would say
I'm a classical liberal which is I would
say a little bit more of a realistic
libertarian but I'm happy to argue where
those margins and where those stop signs
are where those parameters are you want
there to be a healthy balance so what
has to happen to the Democrats I mean
this is sort of I do a lot at the end of
the book that's about exactly this so I
don't want to tip off too much to
suffice to say is I don't see anything
amongst any of the decent Democrats any
of the decent liberals or of the
remaining institutions but they're gonna
put a stop to this
I mean a lot of us have been waving the
flag on this for quite some time and
then what do they do they call us a Nazi
and a bigot new york times run
slanderous pieces on us and the rest of
it so I see no instance where the good
liberals have enough to stand up on
anymore that harkens back to what I was
talking about an hour ago about what is
what is liberalism based in and if it's
only based actually in just how we feel
about things at any given moment then
you can see why it's standing on
quicksand versus why our founders set up
a system that these were god-given
rights these rights came before you
you're born free the government didn't
make you free you're born free the
government can take away your freedom
but it didn't give you your freedom
these are hugely different ways to view
the world
I think clearly you know where I stand
on these things and that's why I often
say now defending my liberal values is
becoming a conservative principle or
defending my liberal principles is
becoming conservative value so what has
to happen I mean to me it seems that
what you just prescribed right there is
what has to happen they have to sort of
the bad ideas of socialism of leftism of
collectivism have to collapse sort of
destroy and eat themselves which they
will right like they will destroy Bernie
one day like he he may have moved the
dial but now he moved the dial and
they're gonna come for him because he's
just an old white man who's got three
houses and he's a multi-millionaire you
know and they'll come for him too and
they have to just they have to just
destroy themselves and then out of that
perhaps a phoenix could rise right like
that's that's the idea there I think
that's it but as I as I say in the book
if you're out there and you're a good
decent liberal you're a blue dog liberal
you're a JFK liberal that's not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country if you don't
want your children to be judged by the
color of their skin which is exactly
what the progressives are offering if
you want something different than that
stand up liberals start fighting fight
the progressives back and prove me wrong
and I'll come crawling back I write it
in the book prove me wrong I'll have a
Mia Copa oh oh man I was wrong on that
one that what a great ending because I
don't need to be right I want this world
to remain sane so prove me wrong people
that would be a pleasure
all right I'm sign-in book plates don't
burn this book calm guys I'm selling our
presale of
my new book and every single copy that
we sell today on July 30th is getting a
signature and I'm signing them right now
and apparently we're doing we're doing
super awesome good on Amazon and some of
the other sites okay here we go
what you do is as I said go to dumper in
this book comm buy the book on Amazon or
on Barnes & Noble indie bound whatever
it is forward your receipt to don't burn
this book at prh comm penguin Random
House dot come and then you can put a
question in there if you want to ask me
a question right now and they will send
you one of these signed book plates
which you will put in your book and you
will know that you bought the book on
the first day of the pre-sale and that's
pretty freaking great alright here we go
ten more J Charles Travis Justin Dewey
Samuel Angela Pierre Joe Kurt and I'll
throw in an eleventh Elliott for now
guys you can delete those and I'll get
back to some of these questions what's
your advice for someone who wants to
make youtube videos but is worried about
what others will think or say I used to
make youtube videos back in high school
but got bullied into stopping but years
later not a day goes by where I don't
think about making them how do I have
the courage not to care what others
think and pursue it do it do it there's
nothing I can tell you other than the do
it then I get this question especially
at the college things because everyone
wants to be a youtuber which is probably
the symptom of something going wrong in
society at some level I say that with
all dir T but do it what would be advice
be well it could be the other advice
don't do what you want to do give up
your dreams don't say what you really
think I mean anyone that gives you any
other advice when you say you know I
want to take a chance I want to take a
chance to do so I'll give you a great
example of this so when I've mentioned
this a couple times here when sargon of
akkad got booted off patreon and Jordan
and I started discussing what to do and
you know our personal circumstances and
finances are very different he was in
the middle of crushing it on the book
store and sold millions and millions of
copies of the book and was doing super
super well from the tour and I'm
obviously
and fine and all that or I'm doing
better than fine but but as I told you
before about 70% of our monthly read was
coming off patreon and a normal person
in business it's not just I'm not just
funding myself here we have several
employees our team is growing you know
we have pulled full timers we have
part-timers all of this stuff we've got
capital and overhead and all all this
stuff right and I wanted to take a stand
and I thought if I cancel patreon and
try to do this on my own like I don't
know what's gonna happen what if I lose
what do I lose that 70% what if no one
wants to come over what not even because
people don't like me what if people are
just lazy like they're just like oh
Kent's patreon I got counseled like I
guess I could go over there but like I'm
busy everyone you know do something on
Netflix like that's it right and you
just forget about it
and I my feeling was I have to do what I
think is right but I did call some
people I called so I don't want to get I
don't want to out anybody but I'm gonna
I'm gonna out one guy here I won't out
some of the other people but I called
several people some of them who have
been on this show so influential people
who are in the business who get it and I
asked several people what they thought I
should do and it's it's pretty rare that
I would call like several people asking
for advice on the same thing but I
really didn't know what to do I knew I
wanted to leave patreon I wasn't sure we
could we could fund this properly you
know finally I felt like my life is sort
of being stable I used to have dead I
don't have dead anymore like all of
these things and I call a couple people
in a couple people who I'm not gonna
mention might surprise you with that
they actually did tell me you know just
suck it up for now this isn't the hill
to die on just let it be you know it'll
blow over you know whatever and then I
called Glenn Beck okay
and I called Glenn Beck and he said like
without hesitation like I was like Glenn
I'm thinking about canceling the patreon
account and he's like yes do it he's
like you got to take risks in life go
ahead and do it and do and do it and he
just he had such passion the way he was
saying it look here's a guy who's taking
big risks in life he bounced around on
some cable channels he was hated for a
long time he's had Mia Culp was about
that I think he's he's a really great
guy I think he's basically a libertarian
who wants to live and let live I think
that you know he's apologized for some
of the mistakes he's made in the past
but he's taken big risks right across
the board and the way he said it I when
I hung up the phone I was like I was
like how can I
take that advice you know like how could
I not take that advice the guy who is
telling me do what I believe in take a
chance take a risk like what does
everyone do in a movie what what all the
heroes do in movies you know the does
the hero get challenges like maybe maybe
tomorrow you know can't someone else do
it you know so I think you just have to
get in so if you want to be a youtuber
even if you want to be a youtuber who
makes videos about how bad Dave Rubin is
how mean Dave Rubin is all day long get
out there and do it and and what I also
tell people is especially on the YouTube
front well now the algorithms are so out
of whack and you guys know I've had some
meetings at YouTube and stuff like that
and I'll talk more about that in
September it's just not the right time
right now but I would say is don't worry
about the numbers put out something that
you think is good put out something that
you think is decent and by the way if
you think that you're gonna put out
something that's good and decent and
you're not gonna get a job for it or
someone's going to attack you for the
mobs gonna come get you as I said before
do you think that by not doing what you
think that you stop the mob you actually
fuel the mob it's the only way you stop
the mob the only way you stop this
collectivist monster that is encroaching
on all of us is to take a stand take a
stand and see what happens and I
guarantee you that they're not gonna
they can't kill all of us right they can
do some horrible things they really can
they can go for some people's jobs they
can make people's lives miserable I've
had my phone number released an email
released and and all sorts of terrible
things happen in the last year related
to that that sort of stuff that I would
generally prefer not to talk about but
it's it's a drop in the bucket compared
to what I think the good thing is which
is all of this and it's why I wrote this
book and it's why I hope when people
take this book that they'll get a little
something so that that they'll come up
to me on the street and go Dave you know
I read this Pete this part in the middle
and you were talking about your belief
on abortion through a classical liberal
lens and I actually take the
conservative approach on that but I but
I heard what you said and I respect your
opinion and I'm going to agree to
disagree
I will gladly take that I will gladly
take that and that's the society that I
want to live in what kind of society do
you want to live it so go to don't burn
this book com buy the book you can get
at Barnes & Noble you can get at Amazon
Apple books wherever it is get the
receipt forward it over to don't burn
book at prh penguin Random House dot-com
prh calm and they will have then your
email address and then they're gonna get
your regular address and you are gonna
get a signed book plate because I am
signing every single book that is sold
on day one of the pre-sale by the way I
realized that in a little bit I suppose
there is a democratic debate but I
promise you you won't learn anything
there if anything you will be dumber by
watching that I hope here maybe you've
learned a little something or you at
least thought about a little something
so oh okay so let me just just liberal
to the questions let's see here do you
have a favorite joke orbit a joke orbit
I don't know what that means
so I have a favorite joke orbit like
type of joke well I'll tell you I'll
tell you just a couple of the things
that influenced me the most comedic Lee
over the years I remember it's so ironic
now because he is the world's most
famous serial rapist but in in about
1983 I was seven years old I write about
this in the book actually I saw a Bill
Cosby himself I remember it was it was
on HBO and I completely remember this I
remember seeing the the HBO intro thing
flying in and I remember being in my
parents living room sitting too close to
the TV my momma's always telling me to
sit away from the TV but I'm sitting
basically with my feet like on the thing
that the TV the TV stand and I'm just
looking up like a you know two feet up
Bill Cosby I'm sure many of you if not
all of you have seen this special it's
called Bill Cosby himself he's in a
brown suit he's sitting on a stool it is
it's comedy perfection basically let's
just put aside everything else about
Cosby for a sec and I remember seeing
that as a seven year old and I didn't
really understand what he was saying you
know he's doing the thing about the
dentist and he's doing the thing about
chocolate cake and you know what it's
like when you have a hangover after work
and all this stuff after partying and
going back to work and I remember
laughing like that that deep pain in the
stomach when you are just uncontrollably
laughing and you can't stop and I
remember thinking like who wouldn't want
to make people laugh and then from that
on from about
six years old so like first grade I just
wanted to make people laugh and that's
what sort of funny about doing stand-up
again because I know on this show when
I'm an interviewer I'm not that funny
there are funny moments but I really
treat this as an interview show and I
want to be respectful of my guests any
other moments where there's some play in
front or whatever but that's also the
nice part of when people come see me do
stand-up because then I meet people
after and they're like man I didn't know
you were funny and that's actually very
refreshing to me it's like a different
part of me like we all have different
parts of ourselves when I'm in this
studio doing an interview I'm an
interviewer that's that's a part of me
when I'm when I'm doing stand-up I'm a
stand-up I but the other nice thing
about stand-up now is I don't really
want to be a stand-up like I don't want
that life like I guess if Netflix wanted
to give me a special or something like
I'd work enough to do it we've been
thinking about doing something where I
go on tour for a couple months and just
basically never tell the same joke twice
and just mess with the crowd and then we
loop that all in together to some
special we've been talking about that
but I don't really want it and it's nice
that when you don't want something it
becomes even more enjoyable to you so so
Bill Cosby himself is one of the major
things that affected me George Carlin of
course of course of course I've got
Kelly Carlin a Carlin Home Companion
George Carlin's daughter her book right
there George Connor was huge huge
influence on me
it would be really interesting to wonder
what George Carlin would be thinking
right now because at some level he'd be
the old white man that the that would
you know that they'd be booing off
college campuses and on the other hand
he was he was a real lefty he always
wanted to fight the power when when
lefty ideas were about fighting the
power but he was a brilliant linguist
and the way he used language and timing
and incredible so most of those George
Carlin specials the last one which I
think is called it's bad for you if I'm
not mistaken it's like his summation of
everything he thinks in the world it's
just absolutely wonderful Kelly told me
years later that he basically knew he
was going to die when that special came
out and you can see him sort of putting
a cap on everything it's just incredible
Ellen DeGeneres the one that's called
in the beginning which is her first
special after coming out is spectacular
honest stand-up it's just just great
Seinfeld was a huge influence Larry
David the
since in the formative years those you
know 1989 when I was you know 13 to
season 8 like around 97 I mean those
years of the Simpson or the symptoms
it's just absolutely nothing better okay
here we go new orders I'll do 20 how
about 20 Jay Charles Travis Justin dwee
Samuel Angela Pierre Joe Kurt Elliott
Barbra Steve Nathan Josh Michael Erika
tangen I'm just keep going because I
think maybe I read some of these dan
eric tony alexander Sean Phillip Jan
Alexander Scott Wesson Casey for Devon
Dana guy Leonardo Justin drew Diane
Julie Kevin Michelle Martin Jared Caleb
Marc Alex Brandon Brandon - Brandon -
the Rope Mike Chris Warren and William
all right we did it there okay let's see
a couple other questions here when when
can we expect yours and Peterson's
alternative so this is this has been
coming up a lot so I always you know I
didn't want to say too much about what
I'm sort of doing solo at the moment and
I don't want to say too much about
what's going on with things but because
Jordan hasn't been too public about it
yet there's a lot of things what I can
promise you is this there's a lot of
things happening if there's anyone on
this earth that can fix the problems
with the tech companies it's Jordan
Peterson
I just firmly believe that I think he's
he's doing the best he can to figure it
out you know he's got some personal
stuff going on that I think some of you
guys know about but I don't want to
really get into it it's not really my
place to talk about it so I think that
that maybe has delayed things a little
bit but trust me if anyone can if anyone
can solve any of this stuff it's a team
that's led by Jordan so that's what I
would say about that all right
I don't know what time it is I've been
going for quite some time I don't think
this is the real time here oh I guess
maybe it is
don't burn this book calm people buy my
book which is up for pre-sale today the
sales numbers seem to be pretty damn
good according to what's going on over
here if you buy the book today I am
signing every single copy I am signing
book plates for everybody whether you
buy the digital copy or the hardcover
copy they will mail them to you the good
people at penguin Random House and then
you can put it in your book or you can
put it on the back of your e-reader or
whatever
you got there and you will know that you
bought the book on the first day and I
really think this is gonna be one of the
big books of 2020 I've given this thing
all I got which is setting me up to to
go off the grid in just a little bit
which I will be doing soon enough we're
gonna tie up a whole bunch of whole
bunch of loose ends tomorrow man I have
a crazy crazy day tomorrow like try to
imagine like getting everything leading
to the book launch and now I have to do
one more day of stuff and and figure out
a whole bunch of things leading up to to
september off the grid but I do hope
that that some of you guys will join me
as I said whether it's just for the
weekends where you put your phone down
or you just try to pay a little less
attention to news now I know I've seen
it when I've tweeted about this I've
seen some people say well then you're
just ceding ground to the crazies and
it's like actually if we're at a point
where you can't take a little time to
recharge the batteries if you can't step
out of the madness a little bit then
we've probably lost already so I would
rather take the risk of whatever that
means to you in your life I understand
that not everyone's gonna have the
luxury to lock their phone in a safe
which is what I'm going to do lock my
phone in a safe maybe we'll do a video
of that and then maybe that'll be the
last thing that I post and oh and by the
way if if you're trying to reach out to
me for anything business-related if you
want me to come speak at your college or
or anything like that
any any gigs that you want or if there's
business opportunities if you've heard
what I've talked about about the tech
stuff or any of that kind of stuff you
can at Dave Rubin comm you can just go
to Dave Rubin comm slash contact and my
team will still be working they'll
forward emails to the appropriate people
and and we'll see what we can do but I
will I will be m.i.a and we'll see how
the brain is functioning and I you know
we know that these things they're trying
to addicted to these screens we know
that they trying to keep us clicking
right and I think there's a there's a
little bit of a way we can all fight it
in our own way so yeah we'll see okay
okay I'll do a couple new orders Barry
Kathleen Jonathan Nick will Elena Howard
Ryan Dexter Sarah Luke Mary Matt Kevin
Jason Taylor Salvador Daniel Megan
Elizabeth David Marshall and Jacob thank
you very much if you guys go to don't
burn this book calm you can buy the book
at either Bynes at Noble or Amazon or
indie bound and then forward the receipt
to don't burn this book at prh calm
that's penguin Random House calm and
then you can include a little question
in there and you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go for it is now 503 Pacific
time I'm gonna go to five fifteen I'll
do 12 more minutes here live and then
and then I'm gonna I don't know what I'm
going to do after this I think I'm
barbecuing tonight for for my sister and
my brother-in-law and the kids I'll do
the barbecuing tonight so we'll do that
okay couple other shout outs Kyle Jeff
Andrea Zachary Michael Sarah Pete I'll
hold the rest for there what else can I
you know I wrote down a few things that
I wanted to talked about about the book
specifically I don't talk about this one
a little bit so one of the things I talk
about is how to fight the mob right
that's been a little bit of a theme of
of what we've talked about here tonight
and you know one of the things about
this is that when you take a position
that is not bigoted or racist or
anything like that that is not really
controversial in any way that's just
what you happen to think that maybe is a
little more Liberty minded or something
like that it's always shocking I think
this is what happens this is the first
moment see that's the thing I lay out
the steps of sort of grief of what will
happen once you start saying what you
think we know what's gonna happen
because this has happened over and over
and over again but it's always shocking
to people the way people turn on them
the venom that people turn on them with
that people that know them suddenly will
say horrible things to them I give some
examples that have happened to me about
that very direct thing that very exact
thing I should say and you suddenly
you're getting hate in places you never
thought you'd get hate and then suddenly
you're looking at the other side and the
other side is kind of going hey we're
here we're
okay maybe maybe we're not that bad
maybe we're kind of like you were and
we're here and you start sort of seeing
the the rejiggering of the configuration
and that again is what is leading me to
be so enthusiastic about everything
right now but what I can tell you is
that when you when you start getting the
hate it's sort of unimaginable at a
certain level and I tell a very personal
story in the book that I'll just tell
you a little bit about right now I've
mentioned this I mentioned this on the
Joe Rogan podcast last time I was on
just briefly and I've mentioned it in
live streams a little bit here and there
but when the show was really taking off
so as I mentioned we kicked off the show
with Sam Harris as an interview show on
or TV September 9th 2015 and then
shortly after that I had Maajid Nawaz on
I had Douglas Mario and I had ayaan
Hirsi Ali on a few other people and I
and all of us were lefties we were all
liberals and we were talking about our
frustrations with the left this is pre
Trump and all that and we were all just
talking about our frustrations with with
our side and subtly I started getting
this endless hate and I couldn't believe
it
no conservatives were angry I mean no
Republicans were angry at me no nobody
on the right was an agreement but
something my own side was saying all
these awful things about me which was
exactly what I had sort of been
predicting and talking about with all of
these people but then it started coming
from personal people from public people
that I knew people that I mean literally
at least one person that was invited to
my wedding I mean crazy crazy stuff and
one day I was getting a haircut and my
girl Jess who's one of my best friends
she's she's my stylist and she had David
come over and she said she said Mabel
might want to look at this and I was
missing a big patch of hair in the back
of my head and then she started looking
around and I was missing several big
patches in the back of my head anyway
long story short after going to some
doctors it turns out that I had I was
diagnosed with alopecia areata which is
basically an autoimmune disease where
your your white blood cells start
attacking your hair follicles they don't
know why
so they chalk it up to stress now I was
under a tremendous amount of stress
suddenly I was getting hate like like
endless relentless hate from the good
is this the the Liberals the
progressives the tolerant decent people
I was getting a tremendous amount of
hate from them from my side and I
probably wasn't dealing with it the best
way possible you know kind of expressed
it here when I do these things with you
but generally in life I'm like a little
more calm and cool and collected and I
don't share every thought that I have
all the time and I'm not the most overly
emotional person let's say which I think
does lead to good to a good ability to
interview somebody in a calm manner but
anyway I started losing huge chunks of
hair and then it started moving to the
top of my head and then we tried steroid
injections courtesans a whole bunch of
stuff and nothing was working and then I
ended up going on a really experimental
treatment which I talked about in the
book that basically causes it's in
effect it's like putting poison ivy on
your head and the hope is that the white
blood cells that are attacking your hair
follicles instead of attacking the
follicles will attack the reaction and
then your hair will grow back anyway I
had absolutely horrific reaction to it
because you're basically putting your
stuff you're allergic to on your body
and at the height now so now the show is
blowing up are you like I'm on the way
up like I'm at the beginning of my
success and I you know I'm being
recognized and I'm being invited places
and all this stuff and things are really
working we're making a little money
things are chugging along and suddenly
I'm dealing with this horrific
affliction that actually at one point I
had lost so much hair on the top of my
head that like I had this like strip
like right here basically the front
strip and I was doing all sorts of crazy
[ __ ] and I was putting you know blank
black powder to cover up spots and then
I was also one of the side effects that
I was I was insanely hot all the time so
you know we're in hot studio lights and
I'd be dripping and sweating and I was
really bloated and like I look back on
videos you can look at some of the
videos that we did in the fall of the
fall and and in early the fall of 2015
and in early 2016 and I look like a mess
like I do not look like myself I look
exhausted and you know big bags under my
eyes and and it was not good it was
terrible actually he was and I really
thought about quitting at one point and
then I tell the story about I was really
thinking about I was like I
that I can do this maybe we'll just do a
radio show maybe I won't do anything
anymore and again this is just as I'm
like on the way up
both are short over the last couple
years I've completely changed my diet
changing my workout thing I mostly do
paleo I do some something called PRP
which is platelet-rich plasma which they
take your blood out of yourself they
spin it in a centrifuge and inject it
back into you and I do that like once
every two months or so and I do have one
or two tiny little spots but this is
this is all my hair it's all real and I
do but I do have one or two tiny little
spots and anyway I mentioned all of this
just to tell you that when you have when
you fight the mob weird things happen
I've talked to some other people that
have fought them up some public people
and they've told me some some [ __ ] that
they've had to deal with or what it's
done to their own personal relationships
or this and that but I would say there
is nothing to not be yourself to not
fight for what you believe in is a far
worse it's a far worse sentence than
losing a little hair or something like
that so I hope that you guys will will
join me on the adventure and how you can
join me on the adventure purchase don't
burn this book free-thinking we change
it so it was gonna be free thinking in
an age of unreason but thinking for
yourself in an age of unreason the four
words by Jordan Peterson which I still
I'm over the moon about if you buy this
book up until midnight tonight I am
gonna sign book plates for as many
people as buy books today I've been
doing shout outs this entire time
obviously I can't do shout outs for
everybody that would be completely
bananas so yeah that's that I think
that's it
okay so I'll answer one more question
here I'm just gonna do you know what if
you I'll do five more minutes so if
you're gonna order the book anyone in
the door is the book in the next from
from now you know it I'll go till 5:20
my time so it is it's 8:20 it'll be 8
2010 so 9 more minutes so anyone that
orders the book and those in those last
9 minutes I'll give you a shout out
here's just a couple more
you fought philip gordon liz brian
andrew jeff matthew chad Larry Carol
Devon
Derek Hayden Mathew and for rescue dogs
Bailey Landry Molly and Daisy Quinton
Joe John Sarah and Cheryl for rescue
dogs did you buy four books for the four
dogs that you got for shoutouts there I
want to know more about that email our
people and don't burn this book at prh
com I want to know who or about these
dogs
okay I'll answer one more question as I
said so we'll go eight more minutes
anyone else that buys the book while
we're doing this and I'm sign-in book
plates people I'm sorry that I can't
personalize these but try to imagine the
logistical nightmare that that would be
but yes there will be a book tour the
book drops on April 28th of 2020 I'm
sure we'll be on tour all of May or June
we've already had some interest in an
Australian tour I've had a couple people
reach out to me in London about trying
to put that together so we're gonna
bounce all over they said oh and as I
mentioned before the international
rights are not sold yet so my agents are
dealing with that right now so I know a
lot of you guys because obviously this
is YouTube and audio podcasts where you
guys are all over the world and I met
you guys all over the world and I get
emailed the amount of email that I get
from India what's going on in India
lately do I get a ton of email from
India and I hope to get to India that
would be awesome I really want to get to
Japan that's the other place that I the
the two places that I haven't been that
I really want to get to are Japan and
India and I really also want to go to
New Zealand the tour with Jordan did go
to New Zealand but I had a family
engagement that I had to leave so I left
Australia and I came back home which
actually was was pretty cool because the
last show that I did was he was the only
matinee show we did of the entire tour
was at the Sydney Opera House which of
course most of you know it's the iconic
Theatre in Sydney right on the water on
the boardwalk there and it was the only
matinee show we did it was a beautiful
beautiful day in Sydney the Australia I
loved loved loved loved loved loved the
Australians like just such fun good
decent people everybody looks good
because it's sunny all the time
the Australian accents are great I went
and hung out with some kangaroos it was
just I just loved every bit of it
but that day everything was sort of
backwards because because it was a
matinee and there were other shows
coming in first up the theatre itself
was incredible it
the only show that we did that was a
true theater-in-the-round so a
theater-in-the-round obviously the
performers in the middle and there's
audience all around you so they have it
sort of it's not round actually it's a
Theatre in a box so you have people in
front of you both sides you behind you
so you're completely surrounded by
people and one of the coolest feelings
that I had the entire tour and as a
performer probably the coolest thing
that I've ever experienced was getting
laughs when they're coming from every
direction I could feel the laughs coming
from behind me and they were like
hitting me in every direction and it was
the last show that we did but was really
cool about that actually was that Jordan
you guys know Jordans on his carnivore
diet so he's only eating steak basically
and at the at the venue there the steak
was pre-made with something and he just
wants it straight up steak no nothing so
even though he had this huge show to put
on and you know it's this iconic theater
at all that we walk out the security
guard takes us out we walk down the
boardwalk with with his wife Tammy he
was wonderful and we walked down the
board welcome people are saying hi to us
the whole time and it's hot out were
wearing suits and we go into it we find
a steak joint we sit in there basically
everyone in the restaurant pretty much
was a fan of Jordans knew who we were
and you know they all wanted to say hi
and the security guard said you know you
should just eat and not say hi to people
and whatever and Jordans made sure to
shake everybody's hand that wanted to be
shake took a picture with everybody that
wanted the picture to be taken and then
we had to run back and then as we're
running back literally people are
high-fiving us like as we're running
back the theatre was just it was just a
great day okay so a couple new orders
Ari Nancy Sarah Justin Eric John Brian
and Ben thank you so anyway as for any
big plans for the last half of the year
we've got five more minutes guys yeah we
got we got big plans so I go off the
grid we come back on September 3rd there
will be a guest host which I think we
just finalized today which I'm really
excited about Ben Shapiro did it last
year we're going with somebody else this
year somebody who all know and it's
gonna be really cool
I might hope oh I will be making one
sort of career show announcement that
day too
which I just can't say more about right
this second due to you know ink drying
on things but let's just say you know
there's a lot of other ways to get
things out there than YouTube
and then my hope also is that this tech
company that I told you I started we've
made some really really great headway
with what we're building and I hope that
we'll be able to launch a beta that day
so beta people that we can get in on
that let's say the master betas they
will we're gonna choose people that are
currently subscribers at Dave Rubin comm
so they'll have advanced warning on that
and then yeah then I want to start doing
stand-up again as I said as twenty20
rolls around we'll get we'll get more
into touring for the book and the rest
of it but you know one of the things
that Jordan said to me all throughout
the tour was you know if we're doing
this he would always say if we're deep
said we I don't think he meant me really
but he would say you know if we're doing
this let's give it everything we've got
why wouldn't we and I that's really how
I feel about about life and sort of what
I'm doing at the moment like let's just
give it everything we've got and and see
what we could do you know like I don't
know maybe if I'd helped I guess inspire
a couple people to stand up for what
they believe in and and that's what I'm
trying to impart on you guys with this
book well then maybe you do it and then
maybe someone else does it and then who
knows what that ripple does yeah it
would we don't know why not try it right
it would it would be pretty it would be
pretty awesome Garrett Steven Paul and
John you guys are getting signed book
plates all right here's my last pitch
guys what's so right now it's it's 5:00
o'clock Pacific we're doing this until
midnight Pacific I can't talk the entire
time till midnight Pacific but if you go
don't burn this book dot-com you can buy
don't burn this book there we go I think
that'll get rid of the glare you can buy
don't burn this book and if you forward
your receipt to don't burn this book at
prh calm penguin Random House dot-com
they will send you can they will come
back to you they'll get your address you
will get a signed book plate which you
can then put in your book nice and neat
or you can put on the back of your book
or you can put wherever you like to put
it and you will forever know that you
bought this book on on day one and I
humbly thank you I cannot believe how
many of these I will be signing this is
actually completely I barely made it
tear this is ridiculous Aaron if you
want to show the table here I know I was
supposed to be signing for these for now
there's gonna I'm gonna have to do this
basically all day tomorrow while I'm
well I'm trying to get off the grid
Luis Heather Kurt and Timothy thank you
guys we got two minutes left guys let's
see there's an interesting question real
quick I have net which I had more time
do you recommend gay conservatives
utilizing their sexuality of running for
office well I would say you know it's
something like the way I do this it's
like if people watch the show for a year
and then and then someone will email me
or meet me on the street and go you know
I watch the show every year I didn't
know you were gay and then I found out
and it's like I don't care you know all
right I hope you're happy
big big whoop you know that's how it
should be nobody she used your sexuality
as a crud Jill and no one should be
treated worse than because of their
sexuality I think that there's
absolutely an awakening within the gay
community if that's a thing within gay
people let's say that they don't have to
be Democrats and I think this is loosely
connected with Candis Owens and what
she's done in the black community which
is basically all she's done is basically
say black people don't have to be
Democrats that's not a offensive or even
remotely controversial opinion of course
your color of your skin or your
sexuality should have nothing to do with
how you vote if in a proper system where
everyone's treated equally so I find it
really interesting what's happened sort
of with the gays where gay people used
to be kind of edgy and and on the
fringes of society and we're really
forward on art and culture and music and
and all and ideas right and now the gay
community through GLAAD and all of these
progressive things have become the
harpist sort of preachy esteemed black
Nothings that they they want to be but I
know many gay people that are not like
that and and they're I look I live in LA
here I gotta meet a lot of gay people
and a lot of times they'll say to me so
that that is one of the things I talk
about in don't burn this book by the way
I actually sort of relate the the being
closeted about your sexuality and I talk
about some of my experiences in that
to being closeted politically and know
what no one should live like that
alright guys it is 5:20 so it is time
let me get these last few people oh I
got more info on those four rescues
Bailey is a Jack Russell mix landries a
small mix molly is a pit mix who was
thrown out of a truck and into a creek
and you found her raw amazing and Daisy
is a shepherd I'm still confused did you
buy four books for these dogs what
happened here this is who knows it's
okay okay in the last few orders that
I'm seeing right now and then I just
gotta get to all the orders I also the
other thing was that there were orders
coming in all day I was just trying to
read what I could get it to here Erin
Andrew Cody Erica and Sam guys it's been
a crazy year as I head off the grid
tomorrow I'll probably send out a little
Twitter thread or maybe up maybe I'll
just do a little five-minute recap video
about going off the grid and all that
but I just want to say like everything
that that I've been trying to do here
it's working and it's coming together
because of you guys and I hope that in
the time when everyone wants to burn
everything down right like that's why we
titled it like this in a time when
everyone wants to burn everything down I
hope you'll try to be one of the people
that doesn't and I know the forces that
be and the powers that be and maybe
human nature kind of push us all into
that and social media makes us all want
to do that we want to own each other and
crush the Lib tards and destroy people
and the Conservatives and all that
nonsense but I think we have a lot more
to lose than than to gain by doing that
and I think we can reset some of this
stuff that's why I wrote this book and I
think the forces that want to keep
splitting us I don't think it's some
grand conspiracy forces what I mean by
that is just human nature and the way we
all behave and the way the political
machines operate and all those things
they all want to kind of divide us and I
think if you step away from some of the
madness a little bit if you really learn
to think for yourself in a time when
people aren't thinking that clearly and
you know why you think things and all
those things that I think incredible
things can happen I just fundamentally
believe that Brittney and David you're
getting the last two shoutouts no wait a
minute I see Beverly being typed right
now so thank you guys I'm humbled and
honored and elated and all that good
stuff bye everything that you've
afforded me to be able to do
so I head off the grid on Thursday I'll
be back on September 3rd as I said big
big career announcement that day
guest host that day we'll talk about the
the tech stuff that day as well
a lots happening and ok I think that is
it all right I feel good about this
thank you guys we're crushing it I guess
on Amazon and we'll find out what's
going on apart into Nobles and the rest
of it so thank you thank you thank you
don't burn this book calm I'm Dave Rubin
saying good night
[Music]